the snake in the Garden of Eden is a
really interesting character human
beings and their closest biological
relative chimpanzees are innately afraid
of and attracted to reptiles they
automatically trigger off responses in a
part of the brain called the amygdala
that's associated with anxiety and I
think the evolutionary reason for this
is that mammals and reptiles have been
at war in a sense over ecological turf
for something between 60 million and 200
million years reptilian features which
are cold blooded piercing eyed toothed
lurking nocturnal out there out and
unknown out where chaos is the snake is
representative of the unknown in a sense
and and it's an ambivalent feature and
you see that you see that even in its
used in mythology because for example
the dragon in in Western culture is a
negative feature but in Chinese culture
it's positive feature and so the unknown
is like that it's positive and negative
the snake in the Garden of Eden is
representative of all those things that
lurk when you think you know what you're
doing and when you think you know what
you're doing you've carved out this
little Eden this little paradise in
which your operates but there's always
something that's lurking and that's all
the things you're not paying attention
to well that's the snake and when that
snake pops up people are we're wired if
a little snake pops out we might want to
run away from it
but like we're curious about that we're
gonna go over there and investigate it
right away
now when chimps come across a Python in
the forest they have a specific cry it's
called a snake rat and the chimps who
don't like snakes they don't run from it
they back off and then they watch the
thing they cannot tear their eyes away
from it and some of them will stand
there and look at it for 10 minutes
other individuals will stand there for
hours watching the snake the unknown is
fascinating we can't look away from it
we have to encounter it even if it's
terrifying it's partly why you know
teenagers like horror movies they're
driven to look at the snake they're
driven to interact with the snake in
Genesis of course interacting with the
snake means the end of
paradise just like it does in life there
are ideas that the serpent in the Garden
of Eden was Satan and trying to destroy
God's handiwork people often look back
in their lives and they say well you
know I got knocked out of my little
paradise by you know this particular
event but looking back on it really made
me grow up it really made me mature
whatever it is that's the serpent in the
Garden of Eden certainly plays that role
it's a catalyst much of what's unknown
is redemptive much of what's unknown
gives life savor it it provides the kind
of excitement that justifies suffering
the injunction behind religious thought
fundamentally is that you should live
your life in such a way that the
suffering it has to contain because
you're confined and vulnerable is
justified